here is video of bolsonaro in a Publix  just kind of like looking around it's  it's surreal almost and he seems to have  security with him  there he is  checking out the register  and it kind of looks like security is  checking out for him which is  interesting I mean that seems like an  interesting grocery store experience  you're just like I'd like this yes sir  yes sir right in the cart and then they  they handle it so so bolsonaro can just  look around  just kind of pacing aimlessly and in  Publix  waves to the person filming uh yeah you  know it did  uh wow did  did you know these granola bars have  four grams of fiber per serving this is  stuff we don't have these in Brazil just  bizarre